the first scene I auditioned with was
Donny's intro scene you showed me it pay
stuff for seventy two thousand dollars
on it I quit my job right now and I
worked for you I had been preparing for
this scene forever I was like had done
everything I possibly could do to make
sure I felt right about those scenes I
started doing it Hey listen I quit and
we do it again and we do it over and
over and over again and he's not saying
anything it wasn't right for him you
know for some reason and Leo's looking
away kind of like uncomfortable we end
up doing it like 50 times nothing and so
I started getting really really nervous
and then he goes all right all right
everyone clear the room let's take a
break and he's like kid come here come
sit with me and he has his own video
Village for about 20 minutes he just
reads the newspaper and I just sit and
stare at the wall and I'm like what the
[__] is going on I'm thinking every
possible thing in my head and after
about 10 minutes or so of freaking out I
just like start to naturally relax like
I'm just kind of chilling out a bit and
then after like 20 minutes he's like all
right let's try one and we did it like
once and that was that